nevada's ranching industry is really
dwindling in part because of a brutal
and persistent drought but also because
of competition from an unlikely source
and that's a public agency veteran
ranchers in nevada say they're being
grounded dust in multiple ways by a
rival operation that happens to be owned
by the southern nevada water authority
the i-team's george knapp reports
you know it only takes 50 years to be an
overnight success veteran rancher hank
vogler has his hands full
it's sheering day when a traveling team
of razor wielding pros sets up shop on
his property to process a long line of
nervous sheep
each one gets clipped shaved then booted
out a chute
slightly stunned but okay huge blocks
stuffed with high quality wool stack up
to form a massive wall around the
operation the harvest from a full year
of tough work in a harsh environment
nevada has been cheap country since the
1800s but vogler knows he's one of the
last stockmen standing we could hold our
convention about right
right there
all of us
or in a phone booth in a good year
vogler's profit margin is slim
but the biggest threat to his survival
these days vogler says is his neighbor
the big guy on the block a sprawling
ranching operation owned and operated by
the southern nevada water authority this
is what i spent my entire life trying to
do and now i'm trying to be shoved out
of business pushed aside destroyed my
entire life savings is going down the
crapper over the past few years vogler
says it's been death by a thousand cuts
he was one of the most outspoken
opponents of snwa's plan to siphon
billions of gallons of groundwater from
rural nevada via a pipeline to las vegas
snwa paid 79 million dollars to buy up
surrounding ranches many times their
market value back then to serve as
anchor properties for the so-called
water grab that multi-billion dollar
boondoggle was formally shelved a few
years ago but snwa has held on to the
ranches and has spent millions of public
dollars to raise cattle and sheep the
ranch manager has had multiple
confrontations with his neighbors he
knew nothing about sheep bogler says his
men have been threatened his equipment
vandalized his water rights challenged
more recently he was charged with
trespassing his sheep on grazing land
he's used for decades you're looking
pretty silly the blm offered to let him
off the hook if he pled guilty but
bogler saw that as a trap and is
fighting back in court against an
opponent with deep pockets of public
money every court motion costs vogler
thousands of dollars mere chump change
to the other guys i just paid a law bill
for last month it's 15 thousand bucks
for one lawyer i now have two
i mean and they're just dragging me down
by my
guts until i go broke bogler doesn't
think government should be in business
competing against smaller private owners
he and his neighbors further argue that
federal statutes are clear no government
entity can have federal grazing permits
but snwa does i'm the fifth generation
another nevada rancher kenna glockner
whose family has lived on the same
lincoln county land since the 1860s says
she's hanging on by her fingernails
because the snwa ranch commandeered the
rangeland assigned to her herds for more
than half a century just took it over
she hired lawyers and won a costly
battle then snwa started a federal
appeals process that will freeze her out
of her range for a decade or more an
expensive process the snwa can afford
but she cannot why are they overrunning
everyone why are they having all these
complaints and battles
and the only
solution i mean the only answer we can
we can come up with is
is that were in their way maybe they
want you to react with violence
absolutely then they can
see what kind of people we have to deal
with
well
i am not the brightest bulb in the
drawer but i am not the
dimmest bulb either
don't try and gaslight me snwa is a
government body competing against
private enterprise we previously asked
how they can graze livestock on public
land when federal regulations state that
government agencies are barred from
getting grazing permits snwa says their
lawyers advise them that they can snwa
declined to comment about vogler's
allegations because they say the matter
is in the courts george knapp 8 news now